the Constitution of the United States so  help me God so help me God  congratulations with the president every  detractor will have to bow down to  president Trump Academy are fake dude  sir can you say good people don't smoke  marijuana there are some people that  need to be prevented from coming into  this country I got a job at Goldman  Sachs where I spent the next 17 years  [Music]  the fact is this man is now president  United States he's tackling very big  issues the ones that he can't ain't on  and one day you execute his one first  100-day plan I know very well he is  committed to making good on the promises  together we will make America great  again  [Music]